huh there's something missing
Nickelodeon has been giving us iconic
cartoon characters for decades but have
you ever wondered who's behind the
voices of these animated legends
[Music]
sorry mr. Krabs but my new philosophy is
scary it was funny
you'll be surprised to find out that Hey
Arnold isn't actually voiced by a
football head or that a surprising
amount of male cartoons were voiced by
women keep watching to see the people
who bring your favorite Nick characters
to life this first voice actor will come
as a total shock Nickelodeon's Rugrats
is one of the most successful shows of
all time it followed a bunch of toddlers
and all of their grand adventures the
ringleader was Tommy pickles he kept a
screwdriver and his diaper to bust all
the Rugrats out of the playpen millions
of Millennials can still hear Tommy
scratchy voice but he was actually
voiced by a woman named Elizabeth Daly
she voiced him again in all grown-up
she's responsible for some other iconic
characters - Elizabeth was the voice of
buttercup in Powerpuff Girls it's hard
to believe that Tommy and Buttercup are
really the same person The Adventures of
Jimmy Neutron boy genius first aired in
2003 it was one of Nickelodeon's early
computer animated series James Isaac
neutron who went by Jimmy was a genius
and inventor in the fifth grade he
created all sorts of advanced -
technologies that usually ended up
getting him and his friends into trouble
but Jimmy wasn't voiced by a fifth grade
boy he was voiced by a woman named
Debbie Derryberry Debbie has been voice
acting for a long time to me all my
characters they can sound the same it's
my voice
she played Diana on both series of
Sailor Moon she even voiced through the
title character from JJ the jet plane
recently she was Maureen on athas for
family
SpongeBob SquarePants is one of the
longest-running kids series ever it's
been on for over 20 years
the yellow eager sponge has become a
complete cultural icon Sponge Bob might
be the single most recognizable cartoon
character in history you know I never
took the driver's test with long pants
but we bet you can't picture who voices
them Tom Kenny has been voicing
Spongebob since the very beginning but
that high-pitched sponge is just one of
many voices Tom has over 491 credits on
IMDB and some of those shows involved
voicing multiple characters his next big
project is Pinocchio in The Adventures
of Pinocchio we hope Tom is willing to
stick around in bikini bottom for a few
more years one crazy animal two voices
cat dog first aired in 1998 it followed
a cat and a dog who were conjoined they
had different personalities and got into
all sorts of mischief cat is a proper
tidy animal white fish chub dog is goofy
and unrefined cat is voiced by Jim
Cummings who was very famous in the
voice-acting world
he's been the voice of Winnie the Pooh
and Tigger for decades
let's get he has over 500 acting credits
on IMDB you've probably heard him in
tons of cartoons and movies dog is
voiced by none other than Tom Kenny yeah
that's right dog and Sponge Bob our
voice by the same person we couldn't
believe it Nickelodeon just doesn't make
shows for older kids they are also
famous for their Nick jr. shows for
preschoolers Dora the Explorer was on
the air for 19 years the show taught
kids some Spanish and also how to follow
directions unlike a lot of cartoons dora
has gone through three different voice
actors the first was Kathleen air leis
who was just 10 years old when she
started she was the longest-running Dora
with over 100 episodes
like the present from 2008 to 2014
Caitlyn Sanchez voiced the character
cartoon she was 12 when she started and
she appears to have left show business
after Dora the final Dora was Fatima
pattach ik the actress is now 20 years
old she stars in an upcoming film called
coast I identify because I felt that way
about Dora when I was younger
Nickelodeon's the loud house is one of
their current animated series it's a
great show all about a boy living with
his huge family Lincoln loud is a great
relatable character the road house has
been on since 2016 but Lincoln has
already had three voice actors she must
be allowed that family the show has
hired three boys but at that age their
voices start to change they keep having
to find new kids to voice the lead
character first up is Colin Dean he was
on the show from 2016 until 2018 next up
is grant Palmer he actually voiced some
episodes at the same time ask Colin but
then he started voicing other characters
most recently Lincoln has been voiced by
Tex Hammond wanna know who's behind the
voice of an even more iconic middle
school boy whoa keep watching to find
out this next character wasn't on a show
but he's a Nickelodeon icon nonetheless
tons of kids in the 1990s and early
2000s grew up watching the mascot Nick
jr. he came on between shows as face and
face was literally just a face we all
remember his tagline hi there face here
so who was the voice actor behind face
Chris Phillips first voiced the
character he is still doing voice acting
but most recently was on butter beans
cafe in phases last year he was voiced
by Bobby Floyd you might know him as the
performer of the pokerap from Pokemon
cares a question
I wonder what today's be Rocko's Modern
Life was a popular Nickelodeon cartoon
that was on from 1993 to 1996
it's a strange a surrealist show about
an Australian wallaby who lives in
America let's just say a lot of the
humor would
have made it into today's kids shows
[Music]
Rocco was voiced by the successful voice
actor carlos alazraqui he's still in the
nickelodeon family playing Carlos on the
loud house and the casagrandes he's also
a regular actor and has appeared as
deputy Garcia on many episodes of Reno
911 was another familiar face you
guessed it Tom Kenny aka Sponge Bob I
can't wait to show Rocko
it's hard to pick a favorite character
from the Rugrats but Chuckie would
definitely be one of our top choices
Tommy's best friend has a lot of issues
they were very different but it worked
whereas tommy was brave Chuckie was
timid and afraid of everything who can
forget his shaky and nasally voice just
like Tommy Chuckie was voiced by an
adult woman this woman's name is
Christine Cavanaugh and you won't
believe where else you've heard her
voice Christine was the voice of Dexter
in Dexter's Laboratory she also voiced
the world's most famous talking pig in
babe Christine was definitely one of the
most iconic voice actors of her time I
can't tell you how grateful I am to
y'all
Nickelodeon's most famous magical couple
is none other than Cosmo and Wanda these
fairies were Timmy's constant companions
on the fairies OddParents and let's just
say they weren't always the greatest at
helping Timmy out these three got into a
lot of trouble
[Music]
daran Norris voiced cosmo on the show he
voiced to Timmy's dad
mr Turner too he also does on-screen
acting you might know him as Johnny
forest from iZombie or cliff from
Veronica Mars Wanda and mrs. Turner were
voiced by Suzanne Blakeslee recently
Suzanne has played mrs. Johnson on the
loud house she is also old lady Crowley
untangled the series everyone loves the
grumpy cynical co-worker of Sponge Bob
Squidward Tentacles is such a great
character because everyone knows a
person just like him Squidward really
puts up with a lot from SpongeBob and
Patrick that's me but the guy who voices
him looks way less grumpy Rodger Bumpass
is the voice actor behind Squidward he's
also voiced to several extra characters
on SpongeBob as well
Roger is no stranger to Nickelodeon he
voiced professor membrane on invader zim
and by clops on chalk zone right now he
is working exclusively on spongebob
roger has been acting since 1979 he
voiced a bunch of characters on the
original series Alvin and the Chipmunks
and finally / two idiots equals stupid
in 2004 Nickelodeon launched a brand new
animated show called Danny Phantom Danny
Fenton was a normal teenage kid until he
got ghost powers and then he became
aware of all of this crazy supernatural
stuff going on in his world he became a
superhero
that has an expiration date here is you
when used his powers to save the world
on a regular basis all while trying to
be a normal team danny was voiced by
David Kaufman David has appeared on
screen and several guest roles and shows
like The Mentalist
he's also voiced to Stuart Little in the
short animated series way back in the
early 90s he was the voice of Marty
McFly on a short-lived animated version
of Back to the Future
he is reprising his role as Danny
Phantom in the upcoming nostalgia show
Nicktoons the loud house introduced a
lot of great characters including Bobby
and Ronnie Ann these two characters are
now on a spin-off show about their own
big family they move to the big city and
meet their extended family the
casagrandes the casagrandes is all about
life in a large Latin family okay I
gotta find out who did this
Ronnie Ann is played by 16 year-old
Isabella Alvarez
Isabella appeared on a few episodes of
shameless in 2014 she also played
Lawrence's daughter on HBO's hit series
Westworld
Bobby is voiced by Carlos Pena Vega the
thirty year old got his start with
Nickelodeon on two episodes of Ned's
Declassified back in 2004 he has two
movies in the works right now and and
this scene was super fun they had real
fireworks Hey Arnold was one of
Nickelodeon's most popular series it
aired from 1996 until 2004 the show
followed a fourth grader named Arnold
and all of his friends through life in
the projects of a big city
Arnold actually had three different
voice actors and their time on the show
overlapped Layne tauren voice to the
most episodes as Arnold you might also
know him as King Bob from Disney's
recess then came Spencer Klein he hasn't
done any acting since the show ended
there's also Philippa Van Dyke he played
Luke in the first Halloween tail movie
on Disney Channel maybe I could show you
around sometime buy you an ice cream
in 1991 Nickelodeon premiered their
first ever animated series Doug was one
of the first along with Rugrats and ren
and stimpy doug was all about a boy
named doug funnie as he tried to
navigate life in middle school to please
thank you he had friends like Skeeter
Valentine and Patti mayonnaise and he
wrote in his diary about his life
Doug was eventually brought back by
Disney and continued until 1999 on Nick
Doug was voiced by Billy West Billy also
voiced both ren and stimpy he is slated
to reprise his roles in the new ren &
stimpy it's our house now video sure
when Doug moved to Disney the actor was
replaced by Thomas McHugh and that's a
wrap so who is your favorite Nickelodeon
cartoon character of all time let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
the things give this video a big thumbs
up and don't forget to click subscribe
see you next time